the hair is perfect the waves and the
doctor is wonderfully back home
everything's great
hey you little [ __ ] Mouse he's here
Donald Trump has come to Germany
actually to Germany's carnival capital
cologne no idea what he's up to maybe to
make kind of upgrade again he's
everywhere right now at nearly every
carnival event like here at colognes
amis it's on for immigrants who have
moved to cologne from around the world
put on costumes and make fun of touchy
political issues Oh
with a hint of self mockery and of
course Trump is part of it he offers so
many possibilities and he himself gives
us so much to work with already we only
have to exaggerate a little and they
have it of course there's what he says
but it's also how he acts that's another
reason why the character of the US
president is so popular at carnival not
just onstage demand for Trump costumes
is huge yes of course we have them when
I was heading toward the final days in
November and it became clear that he'd
be President
we had were specially made luckily but
in the end they weren't enough and
that's why they're all sold out but
there are alternatives the most
important thing is their blonde and the
part is on the right side slap on the
fake tan and voila carnival carnival
first
Trump also shows up at a highlight of
Carnival season two Rose Monday parade
on the float
he's the new badly behaved school boy in
a classroom of world politics it's in
fact a float that we only just designed
in a final stretches we didn't know how
crazy it would get and here we have a
lot of absurdities altogether from
grabbing under the skirts of Lady
Liberty makes a pretty clear statement
it shows how he treats freedom how he
treats women it's me misfire on phone
get Donald Trump is a great target for
Carnival actually he's the best all the
other targets their faith to losers it's
no surprise then that you're bound to
beat one Trump or another on the streets
of Cologne why are you dressed up from I
am I just can say America first but
Germany second I love America America
first and liberty first but not Trump
first poking fun at politicians is all
part of Carnival but most people are in
it for the fun regardless of how serious
world politics may be at least until Ash
Wednesday
[Music]